then we play we kick off our garage
series road trip a two-part series I'm
inspired by the many Technology
scenarios we've had on the show and I
decided to hit the road well by playing
first to meet some of the people and
organizations adopting office 365 and I
want to put office to the challenge
while I'm navigating my way
first stop Hong Kong known for its
expensive skyline where the traditional
and modern walk hand in hand but before
we get started let's have a look at
today's trivia question what is the
average number of devices in news per
person in Hong Kong is it a B or C in
this city efficiency is key there are
about 400 square miles of 7 million
people inhabiting Hong Kong the lack of
space is made at one of the world's most
vertical cities and here more than ever
there's an imperative need for the
people and industry to move towards the
cloud so what better way to understand
the move to the cloud and to catch up
with some real customers and real
organizations starting that journey
today I'm here at the ignite conference
the first in Hong Kong who are 300
people are beginning their journey and I
want to get their perspectives on office
are you looking to learn this week
what's your what's your main topic for
office 365 we're looking at deployment
change management 119 you want new
friends for Microsoft Office
physics-defying
I'm looking at SharePoint today what
pain points or problems are you looking
to solve with the move to the cloud
really the transition to the cloud many
of the companies in Macau are expanding
right now right all of you link and
share planting became he enhanced on the
collaboratory call deprivation how to
move them from that legacy platform to
2013 office 365 so when we talk about
cloud and we talk about Microsoft one
thing which comes to our mind is office
365 what's your favorite capability for
office 365 or anytime anywhere globally
it is very important they can use the
lane they can use the shop on to have a
to communicate with others how many
devices do you actually use between your
phones and your PCs and your Mac's every
day I own three devices iPhone some
Tibet and of course after PC in the epic
trip to you see PC man mobile phone iPad
one workstation at office a notebook in
the office two tablets at home so for
like full win eight devices tablet and
phones would be much easier if you can
just install office on all these devices
are not really worried about or exactly
and have everything synchronized
Hong Kong is often referred to as the
gateway to China but it's really much
more than that
you see Hong Kong is built on trade
currency physical goods and also
services that means the appetite for
technology and services is much higher
than it is say in other parts of China
where they can throw people at a problem
as opposed to solving that with
technology an organization that is
rapidly expanding its trade and services
as Hong Kong's Emperor group it is
famously grown from a jewelry store and
watchmaker to a large conglomerate of
multiple businesses to learn more on how
they are managing their astronomical
expansion i sat down with their
technology director Kenneth Lam the meet
are changing and then so that right now
that really not only focus on in Hong
Kong more we expand our business to
cover the equipt China Singapore and
original and then so right now that we
need to knock some nine new tools to
help to our business to get more
communication instantly it's just like
that I mentioned that right now they we
have so dai diversify our business unit
and then the employee also see in
different office and then so that but we
need to have the well communication
between each other so they otherwise
that we are just working in sidle
walking around Hong Kong I see a lot of
different retail stores and per group a
lot of that you've got your media
division doing filming and TV production
and all of these things so there's prey
of IM phasis on mobility and other
platforms maybe mac and pc windows
support and all the different phones
that they might be using how do you see
like the mobile story with office 365
benefitting you yeah I think that one of
the key strategy our key IT strategies
is a mobile and kow what we call the
edge technology that can help the
business to do the business faster and
then more kind of the coach to the
customer so mobile and cloud strategy is
one of the hour tops
IT strategy within the group and then
365 is quite match this kind of
requirement and are you saying that's
really bringing bringing back all of
these because you've grown so
explosively in all these various
business units have you seen office 365
bring that together a bit yeah right
because in the old days that when they
have a traveling or when they visit the
customer probably that they let off the
instant-message or things that will help
them to keep update all these happen to
happen things to them so right now when
we have a 365 they can get their instant
message they can get that ye may email
all the things instantly excellent well
thanks for sharing your story with us
today
Kevin so the connection between mobility
and cloud services adoption is pretty
indisputable and perhaps the strongest
driving force behind this trend is Hong
Kong's youth so how are educational
institutions managing this change I set
out to Hong Kong's largest publicly
funded University Pauly you to speak
with CIO Jared ball Minh well the
university is the largest funded
government-funded University of Hong
Kong
it has 33,000 students about 4,000 staff
it's been an existence since of its in
1937 its researchers is often very
focused on alignments with industry so
tell us about in terms of mobility some
of the trends that we're seeing with
your students are people come in with
more and more devices these days to get
their studies and their work done yes
they sure the universities got wireless
fabric throughout the whole of the
campus and we've seen a 300% increase in
12 months of the number of connected
devices Wow so it's not about load it's
about how many devices people are
carrying around and often you'll see
students with one two three devices
exposed at once so it's a it's a real
issue excellent in terms of like office
office 365 and some of the email
workloads to support those devices what
was it like prior to
to you looking at office 365 and
implementing those services so we were
we were it's really two dimensions to
this one is student email and there's
some quite interesting problems there
one of which was a proprietary email
solution unable to be extended to the
Graduate community the alumni 330,000
graduates so we had a licensing issue
around being able to extend that in the
staff space we had a legacy email system
very functional lots of features
somewhat disconnected features sometimes
with challenges around mobility unable
to easily and take the email to the to
the smartphone so we were seeing clergy
solutions multiple email systems and
lots of user complaints about the
inability to to reach out collaborate
and and to move to a mobile space right
so tell us about the deployment
experience if you had all these
disparate kind of systems in place
alumni versus non alumni support all
those things and different systems it
sounds like internally and for staff how
did that all come together with office
365 gradually as far as the staging was
concerned we went to the students
Student Service first so we use the the
a jus service Hydra Live service and
that's now been migrated to office 365
and then we also contemplated moving our
staff system to exchange and in-house
solution and the conversation we had
with Microsoft about that option led to
the possibility of a going to the cloud
excellent so I decided also that I'm
going to put office 365 to the test and
really use it help me navigate my way
through Hong Kong City so thanks for
joining us Jarret well you're gonna use
your SharePoint facilities I'd say yes
definitely thank you
so I've had a great week in Hong Kong so
far I've talked to a lot of great people
I've presented at the ignite conference
but now I want to experience the city
and what I want to do is use office 365
as my guide using the apps for office
and web services behind those apps for
office to really help me navigate the
city in all the places that I want to
see in this case I'm going to search for
a few markets a few traditional and
cultural areas that I want to visit and
the great thing is I can call into
services like Wikipedia by using apps
for office to get a back story of all
the different markets I want to see all
the different temples I want to visit in
all the different landmarks I would like
to I'd like to explore so the great
thing is with apps for office as well is
that I can use the Bing translation
service in the apps there in order to
create a translation of the location
that I'm wanting to go to and that means
that if I'm in a taxi because I'm
storing the documents centrally in
Office 365
I can pull that document up from my
phone very quickly and show my taxi
driver in this case the traditional
Chinese characters to help me navigate
to those locations so I'm going to plan
out my entire trip and I'm going to have
all the different destinations already
included in my word document and that's
gonna really help me navigate through my
entire rest of the trip in Hong Kong so
if you've ever traveled to Asia you know
the drill you usually get these types of
business cards now the problem is if I
lose that business card I won't be able
to get to my destination the nice thing
was I was actually able to save my
document centrally using SkyDrive pro
and office 365 and I can access that
follow along with the Chinese
translation in order to help me
communicate with the taxi driver let's
try it hello can you take can you take
me here yes okay yeah okay yeah
so cool that worked and with my office
365 OneNote guide in hand via the cloud
we set off to man mo temple
now my next stop the wet market I made
my first attempt at real-time
translation using my tablet to scan
signs and the Bing cloud service to
translate
I used it all the way to the Chimchar a
ferry and then as the Sun started to set
on Victoria Harbour souvenir shopping in
this 24-hour City was on my mind I
headed to a street market and with
haggling not my strength I enlisted the
help of Lincoln office 365 and my friend
Steve eeveelution Karla oh whoa okay so
we'll give all we'll get all the punk
okay so we'll Ponyo Steve Tokyo sure hey
what's up hey Steve so I met the I'm at
the store here I found I found the
jacket I wanted can you check if this is
if this is the one you're thinking of oh
nice 110 here too much 120 in Tosh War
II by E by Usher choir try your best
okay so you see saying it's worth 150
Wow that's fine 150 okay okay the XXL
okay so I got for 150 it may be those
cheapest well done
okay okay okay thank you
so I've used office 365 as my guide to
Hong Kong and wow what a city but I
can't leave this place without savoring
the local cuisine
so I've spent a few years living in
China when he come to Hong Kong while
most menus are bilingual once you at the
mainland all bets are off now I've got
here Albert's and Quinn from the
office365 team because I really wanted
to experience Chinese cuisine with a
restaurant that caters to mainland
tourists guys yeah gonna love to food
here
I've ordered a couple of the chef's
recommendation I had a couple of my
favorites as well
I'm excited he's - it's great it's great
dig it in yeah Albert
this looks amazing so tell me which
dishes did you order say auditor picking
up the broccoli with scallop and my
favorite fish ball but hang on a second
what is that is that a starfish yes it
is a starfish and what what's underneath
it what is this plate called you know I
don't know let me check me - Rita okay
wait at the hunt I've never had starfish
before know what's interesting though
okay let me check what the chef's
recommendation all right
Oh Oh guys I can speak Chinese but I
can't read okay well I can't read either
I can I've actually got my Windows
tablet with me and I've been using this
all week to be to translate and really
help now we get my way through Hong Kong
oh cool
so in this case because the the menu is
in simplified Chinese I can actually
point it right at the right of the dish
and I can see we've got cuttlefish out
here it looks like that's probably the
white one we also have starfish world
soup so it's probably the starfish plus
some of the other things in that
starfish's world and it looks like we've
got we've got sea cucumber that is this
one right so we've got sea cucumber
cuttlefish and starfish there it is
so all of that's working right right off
of Bing Translate so using the same
engine that we use within office 365
and you just take a picture of the menu
and it's just scanning it real-time
right off the menu from Chinese going to
the cloud doing the translation and then
putting the words in English directly on
the screen for oh wow very nice very
cool so and then if I wanted to use it
say for example I'm traveling and I
don't speak English well because the
menus again are bilingual typically with
English and Chinese
what if I'm French or German I can
select the languages that I come to or
that I read from and then translate into
so I've got a lot of flexibility with
more than 20 languages well that that's
neat
but you know what would be neither what
can it actually translate the other way
so could I go for instance from English
to Chinese yeah that's that's actually
pretty easy so all we have to do is
select English then as our as our
starting language and in this case we
can select we'll do Chinese traditional
here and then if I if I type in the word
what dish are you thinking about well I
would love to order mongolian beef
because I didn't see that out here
that's one of my favorites okay that
yeah I don't recall having a lot of
mongolian beef when I lived in China but
we can take a look and see if they can
if they can serve that certainly and the
cool thing is once it translates that
into into Chinese I get the character
and I can also listen to the audio of
what of what that is if I want to
actually enunciate that in proper time
does the written translation and it
doesn't audio yeah I'm just well well
let me try it let me check so you and I
could check we do Veda okay beta
I don't think they have mom go ahead
babe don't you do what I was trying to
order with you exactly
all right cool you know let's actually
enjoy what we've got here
before we wrap up let's have a look at
today's trivia answer so the answer the
trivia question was a on average Hong
Kong citizens have more than 2.3 devices
per person that they're using to connect
to the cloud every day this has been
such a great city and a great trip I've
caught up with some of the early
adopters of office 365 and I've used the
technology to navigate my way through
the city of course all this information
and more can be found at Microsoft calm
/ garage thanks for watching we'll see
you next time